el ángulo está circunscrito a la
circunferencia con centro en o entonces
aquí podemos observar nuestro ángulo a
la verdad que está justamente
circunscrito a esta circunstancia y el
centro está aquí y es el punto o verdad
y cuando nos dicen que un ángulo está
circunscrito a un círculo verdad en
realidad lo que significa es que estos
segmentos serían parte de líneas
tangentes así que de hecho de hecho voy
a intentar dibujarlo esto por ejemplo
sería parte de una línea tangente y éste
también sería éste sería un segmento
digamos parte de otra línea tangente
verdad entonces aquí podemos ver que los
puntos c y b son justamente los puntos
de tangencia entre la circunferencia y
estas líneas verdad nos dicen cuál es la
medida del ángulo a entonces lo que no
conocemos es justamente la medida d
este ángulo y como siempre te invito a
que hagas una pausa trates de resolverlo
por tu propia cuenta y después lo
hacemos todos juntos
bueno para abordar este problema hay
distintas formas de hacerlo pero digamos
una de ellas es notar que el bueno hay
que recordar que los radios estos radios
son siempre perpendiculares a las líneas
tangentes que intersectan verdad así que
podemos ver que estos dos ángulos este
ángulo de aquí y este ángulo de acá son
dos ángulos rectos son ángulos de 90
grados y la otra cosa que hay que
recordar es que la suma de los ángulos
internos de cualquier cuadrilátero tiene
que dar 360 grados y es que aquí tenemos
un cuadrilátero verdad tenemos el
cuadrilátero a b o c y conocemos tres de
sus ángulos es de 90 grados este también
este es de 92 entonces ahora podríamos
deducir cuánto mide este ángulo
desconocido verdad entonces lo que
tenemos es que 92 grados
90 + 90 que nos da 180 verdad más
nuestro ángulo que no conocemos vamos a
llamarle x más x nos debe dar 360 grados
y la razón por la cual es que la suma de
los ángulos internos de un cuadrilátero
es siempre 360 grados es que podríamos
incluso a partir por ejemplo a la mitad
y obtenemos dos triángulos y la suma de
los ángulos internos de cada uno de
ellos es 180 pero tenemos 2 entonces nos
da 360 entonces es la la razón por la
cual la suma es 360 grados ahora
podríamos restar 180 de ambos lados
verdad y que es lo que tendríamos 92 más
x nos da 180 y ahora restamos 92 de
ambos lados entonces tendríamos x igual
a 180 menos 92 por ejemplo 180 menos 90
serían 90 y ahora restamos 2 nos da
88 entonces la respuesta es cuál es la
medida del ángulo a la respuesta es 88
grados muy bien vamos a hacer otro
ejercicio vamos a hacer otro ejercicio
resultan ser bastante divertidos de
verdad nuevamente nos dicen el ángulo a
está circunscrito a la circunferencia
concentró en no aquí tenemos el ángulo a
y esta es la circunferencia cuál es la
medida del ángulo de ahora nos preguntan
por la medida de este ángulo que no
conocemos verdad
entonces la clave de este ejercicio es
recordar como en el ejercicio anterior
que podríamos encontrar cuadriláteros y
encontrar estos ángulos de hecho otra
vez tenemos estos dos radios los radios
van del punto a al punto ce verdad por
ejemplo entonces aquí tenemos un ángulo
de 90 grados ya que el ángulo está
circunscrito verdad lo mismo ocurre con
este ángulo que tenemos aquí verdad
entonces ya tenemos este ángulo a que es
de 80 grados tenemos estos dos y cada
unos miden
90 grados entonces podríamos tratar de
calcular este ángulo que tenemos aquí
que voy a llamar de verdad porque
nuevamente tenemos un cuadrilátero el
cuadrilátero a b o c y la suma de los
ángulos internos de este cuadrilátero
debe ser 360 grados así que vamos a
ponerlo aquí tendríamos
y este ángulo de 80 grados más 90 más 90
esto nos da ciento ochenta 180 debe ser
360 grados verdad entonces restamos 180
de ambos lados tendremos más 80 será
igual a 180 y ahora restamos 80 de ambos
lados y obtenemos que ya vale 100
verdad' 180 menos 80 nos da 100 entonces
este ángulo de aquí es es igual a 100
grados lo cual nos dice que la medida de
este arco este arco verdad que es
justamente el que está definido por el
ángulo y la medida de este arco es
también de 100 grados verdad esa es la
definición de la medida de un arco
entonces si nosotros recordamos nosotros
queremos calcular el ángulo x y podemos
observar que es un ángulo inscrito y
este ángulo inscrito que mide xy que no
conocemos
sostiene a este mismo arco del cual ya
sabemos su medida y que son 100 grados y
ya hemos visto en vídeos anteriores que
la medida del ángulo inscrito será igual
a la mitad de la medida del arco verdad
eso significa que la medida de este
ángulo x será de 50 grados que es la
mitad de 100 grados entonces cuál es la
medida del ángulo de la respuesta es 50
grados y hemos terminado